agents are assigned the critical task of
investigating a Boathouse along the
Potomac River which has become a hub for
the outcasts to transport and stockpile
weapons and supplies
their mission is to thoroughly explore
the location uncover the extent of the
outcast activities and confiscate or
destroy any weapons they come across
[Music]
amidst the escalating tensions reports
emerge of the outcast strategically
stockpiling weapons and suppliers in a
Boathouse along the Potomac River
the division agents are swiftly
dispatched to investigate this threat
and seize the Arsenal to ensure the
safety of the city
the agents embark on their mission
aiming to disrupt the outcast Supply
route along the river
the first objective is to reach the
Passenger Terminal where the illicit
activities are believed to be taking
place
with caution and precision they navigate
through the terminal neutralizing any
hostile forces they encounter and secure
the area to proceed
as they Advance the Agents come across
closed shutters blocking their path
determined to uncover the truth they
open the shutters revealing a hidden
passage leading to The Boathouse
reaching The Boathouse the agents are
met with the site of numerous women
stockpiles
knowing the potential danger these
weapons pose in the wrong hands they
make the call to destroy them reducing
the outcast Firepower and crippling
their operations
as they locate and eliminate the three
weapon stockpiles scattered throughout
The Boathouse they are faced with heavy
resistance from the outcasts
surviving the attack having accomplished
their mission of removing the weapon
stockpiles from hostile hands they
Retreat from The Boathouse leaving
behind a crippling blow to the outcast
operations
I can't believe the jtf would just lead
people to die like that rumor is it
wasn't a jtf some group calling
themselves the true Sun shut down the
quarantine that's sick it's more like
true I wish there was something
we could do to help them we've got the
boats when the next eight package comes
in we skim a little off the top and
deliver it to the quarantine
I don't know
we're doing the right thing we're not
just going to let those people starve to
death
[Applause]
two Marina employees expressed their
disbelief and outrage over a group of
jtf's Abandonment of people in need
although it is confirmed that it is a
new group called The True sons who are
responsible for shutting down the
quarantine
together they make the decision to take
action and provide essential supplies to
those in disparate need refusing to let
them suffer and starve
a reference to the early days of the
outbreak in DC with a jtf on Roosevelt
Island abandoned their position and
Rebrand themselves as the true Sons
this shows that not everyone was willing
to sit back and let the people on the
island starve to death which is
interesting because not only did
Emmeline Shore in the outcasts rise up
because of the true sons and jtf but
also because they felt that the rest of
society just sat back and allowed it to
happen
if they knew individuals were going out
of their way and risking their lives to
bring them supplies would they have
risen to become such a destructive force
once they escaped the island
I know you gave up a lot to make sure I
had a way out of DC
I promise I'd be careful
I won't let you down love you Mom see
you soon
come on you gotta let me on the boat you
were late it's not my fault there was a
shooting they blocked the road and I had
to find a way around it yeah that sucks
come on I have to get on that boat I
promised you're not getting on until you
pay the fare I don't have any cash
take cash
that's a nice locket though I can't it
was my Grammys then it must be real
fine
you don't want to hide your phone
why they're gonna search you take
anything of value they already took my
locket I don't have anything else
your phone still work yeah then you have
something this is so up I thought
these people were supposed to help us
I love you Mom
I love you too be careful you're not
going with us you two take care of each
other she's not coming why isn't she
coming
they increased the price we didn't have
enough to pay for both of us
that's not fair what's fair anymore
foreign
of the outbreak Kara Wong finds herself
in a Race Against Time to board a boat
and reunite with her mother
however she encounters a group claiming
to offer assistance
but their demands and obstacles reveal
their true intentions of exploiting the
disparate situation
these interactions paint a grim picture
of the post-outbreak reality
where survival can the cost of
sacrifices and compromises
the ruthless opportunists lurking In the
Shadows preyed on the disparate
capitalizing on their suffering and
profiting from their desperation
this is a stark reminder that in times
of Crisis the inherent goodness of
humanity could be overshadowed by greed
and self-interest
[Music]
the more of these I play through the
more disappointed I get for not really
digging into these columns properly in
year one admittedly there was a lot of
information coming at us during that
time so these were somewhat
insignificant in comparison to the main
storyline playing out in front of us
but now having run through a lot of them
they do quite a good job of painting the
picture of what it was like in the early
days something that I thought the
division 2 actually lacked in comparison
to the original game
I have a few more to get through but
they don't take me too much time so I'll
hopefully head these out over the next
few days
thank you once again for watching these
videos and extremist malice extreme
remedia
[Music]
[Applause]